Hi, everybody. Thank you for your time today and
welcome to DVT 216.
Um,
we're thrilled that you're here with us this morning. Thank you very
much for coming to Reinvent. Thank you for spending the next
hour with us
on this, the final day, the last gong
of um Reinvent 2025.
Uh, we got it, we made it.
Well done team.
I hope everybody's had a truly excellent week.
Um, hopefully, you got to make
some new friends along the way, caught up, and you catch up
with some old friends. I, I hope you learned something new
and I, I, I hope you felt a little bit inspired along the way
cause that's certainly what
Reinvent feels like for me.
Uh, so thank you for being here. We appreciate you joining us
this week. So because it's
Friday, and we shouldn't have to put any
brain cycles into anything too taxing
today, we've decided
uh that today's session is only gonna be staged
by Paul's. That way, you can go back home
with a little bit of, um, you know, more
content in your head. Hopefully the content from today's session,
um, and you don't have to remember one more thing.
So thank you again for your time. My name is Paul Stafford. Um,
I'm part of the worldwide team that looks after
our customers'
growth and success with,
um, Quiro and Q Developer.
I've, I've been with AWS for 6 years
now. Um, and I'm based in
Melbourne, Australia.
Uh, prior to this, I've been a product director
and a solution architect and business development
manager,
uh, and a developer as well. Uh, in fact,
I, I think of myself mostly as a recovering
developer.
Uh, I cut my teeth
way back in the day,
building JAppy integrations between
carrier grade voice systems. If there are any
tap heads in the audience that want to reminisce about the
scars and the good old days,
please come find me afterwards.
Uh, I love chatting about that stuff.
Um, but I'm also thrilled to introduce
you to Paul Thrasher, who is the far
better Paul, um, the Paul with the cooler
last name certainly,
um, who's graciously agreed to
share the stage with me today.
Uh, thanks, Paul. Um, so
I'm Paul Thrasher. I'm
project director for Agentic Fabric
at IBM, uh, Hash Corp,
now IBM,
um,
and Agentic Fabric is doing,
uh, AI projects within Hash Corp board.
Um, so I started way back
in the day with, uh, a
Bachelor of Fine Arts in Design.
Been a programmer for over 16
years, I was doing.
Um, PHP at first, but I got in
a, you know, Python,
no JS Go,
Swift,
um, been really loving SWIFT lately.
Uh, I've been with Hashicourt for
a, a bit over 8.5 years and
got into,
uh, product management about
3 years ago.
Um, since then, I was,
uh, became
director of product for the,
our Terraform ecosystem.
So at first managing providers but also
doing, you know,
partner integrations,
um, and now, now I'm doing
AI for, for all of Hash Corp up here.
So, um,
you know, I've been all over the place
so I think at this, this point
I just like to build stuff so here
we are on stage building some stuff.
Awesome.
Fantastic. Thank you very much, Paul. Much appreciated.
So, rather than,
uh, I suppose, uh, show you a very sequential
agenda slide, which I'm sure you've seen enough of during
this week, uh, we thought it'd be a good idea to
give you a synopsis of what you're gonna hear and see
over the next 60 minutes,
followed by some topic specifics. And that
way we can effectively convey both
the thematics as well as the molecules
of what it is that you're gonna hear about in this
breakout session.
In In what is probably the,
in what is probably the understatement of the week,
I'm gonna say that agents are undergoing
significant transformation.
What used to be assistive tooling is now
quite sophisticated and autonomous.
And at its crux, that's what you're gonna hear
today. You're gonna hear a story of change.
We're gonna talk how um agents and their use
cases have changed. We'll talk about how the SDLC
is in the progress and the process of changing.
Uh, we'll talk about how services like Hiro have
changed, but most importantly, we'll also focus
on, um, Hashi Corp and, uh,
the change that they went through to solve one of their
most pressing challenges by using, um,
uh agentic AI within their SDLC.
Uh, importantly, you're also gonna see the practical
reality of the human agent partnership
in action. And it is a partnership
where agents have become active collaborators,
uh, with us, with developers in the,
uh, in the development process.
So, in creating the
session, Paul and I wanted to ensure that
uh all of the topics in the next 60 minutes
were underwritten with a very followable
how and what
format.
Uh, so based on a rough calculation of time and
slides, the next 60 minutes is gonna
be divided um thusly.
And as you can see, we're gonna put, put a bit more time
into the how slides and the how details.
And rightfully so, this is a level 200 session.
Uh, so we will cover the evolution of agents,
the human, um, agent partnership. We'll go into
Agentic AI across the SDLC.
We'll have some demos.
Um, we'll obviously talk about Hashhy Corp's
challenge, and then we'll talk about tooling and
MCP will be an element,
uh, of that. So if we do our job properly,
we'll hopefully get you thinking about not just the
technological change, but we'll also get you thinking
about the paradigm shift that folk are going through
as they, uh, as they, as they're approaching
software development in late 25 and,
and obviously next year as well.
So you'll spend roughly the next twenty-ish
minutes with me, um, and we'll go through that
contemporary evolution concept.
We'll talk about patterns, we'll talk about use cases,
we'll talk about adoption.
And then Paul will take the stage for the good stuff.
Um, Paul's gonna talk,
uh, through some demos that he's recorded,
and he'll talk on the reality of how this works for Hashi Corp
and the benefit that they've seen and drawn
into their own customers and their own partner,
partner ecosystem.
But if there was, if there was only one thing that you took away
from today, and if there was only one thing that you recalled,
um, in the weeks to come,
Paul and I would really like it to be um
this quote from this session.
Yes, AI agents can create and achieve
great things, but it's the human who provides
the contextual and tooling wisdom, the
strategy that prevents agents from assuming
in the dark.
Now, we'll revisit this quote later on
in the slide deck. We'll decompose it further once we've gathered
a little bit more detail through the course of the session.
What are AI agents? Autonomous or semi-autonomous
software systems that can reason, plan, and
act to accomplish goals in digital environments.
Uh, you may have seen this definition knocking
around on the internet recently, uh, in
the last couple of days. And whilst I understand its
intent, I'm not really a fan of it.
I prefer
an agent is a system that you give
agency to complete a task
according to independence,
tooling and context that you allocate.
These days, Agentic AI is context-aware,
um, it is proactive in its actions,
um, and it can maintain continuity over tasks.
And when you wash everything else away, it's
these three concepts that enables
us to partner effectively as humans,
as developers, working with the agents
themselves. And this is obviously, uh,
in all in the purpose and the intent of
having an intelligent collaborator in
our software development activities.
So, I thought it worthwhile putting a couple of points of definition on
the table right at the get-go because there is
some ambiguity around terminology
with Gen AI and agentic AI and everything
in between.
At AWS we think of generative AI
as this three-layer stack. I'm sure you've seen
this during the course of the week uh or maybe previously.
Um, at the bottom, we have,
uh, services, infrastructure services that our customers
use to build and train their own models.
In the middle is Amazon Bedrock, which is used
to create generative AI applications.
And then at the top is the agent-based managed
AI services such as Qiro and Q Developer.
At AWS we consider
AI agentic AI to be about task
management,
um, and specifically toil-based task.
And I'll say that word a lot during, during the next sort of 15
minutes, toil.
Um, this is where you give a large language
model agency to complete something
on your behalf because as it turns out, having an agent
that you can allocate an activity to,
uh, is a powerful productivity and efficiency
concept.
And part of the reason for that productivity
and efficiency is simplicity.
Because agents are actually only composed of four main
components,
uh, memory, which is where the LLM sits,
um, tools, which is all about integration,
powers, and MCP lives here, and that's
a little bit of a foreshadowing for what's to come with
Paul a little bit later in the hour.
Um, and then planning, which is, um,
yeah, self-management, workflows,
separate data sets, and so on.
And of course the final thing is, is, is outcome,
which is the actual task that you've given to the agent
itself. One of the key reasons
why agents are becoming uh increasingly
attractive is because of the generational advancements
of the technology and integration
in all of the tech behind these concepts.
And I, I promised Paul
I wasn't gonna mow his lawn too much with the slide.
My apologies, Paul,
but it would be shameful of me not to mention
that Hashi Kor obviously contributes
significantly to the tool and planning
elements with Energetic AI through the
technology and services that they, that they have
created. Uh,
one further point of definition for the table
before we go any further, if you don't mind. Um, we're
seeing customers drive value with Agentic
AI across two primary categories,
accelerating software development and reimagining
workflows across the business.
The, uh, the prior is about using AWS,
uh, pre-built Agentic services, and the latter
provides the tooling for building your own agentic solutions.
For the sake of today, we are focusing
only and solely on the prior. We're
focusing only and solely on accelerating
software development.
So
When Ergenic Services first appeared
on the scene, they were almost solely um
coding companions. They, they, they helped developers
with the ideas of things like code completion and auto
suggestion, which was and is
quite a polarizing topic for many developers.
The, the playground of
early Agenic AI was phase
3 of the SDLC which was
all about what developers do through an IDE
as part of the design activities and associated
process. So, in the dawn days
of Agentic AI, which granted was only
2-ish years ago or so,
the value of something like Agenic AI and its
benefits was quartered behind qualifications
like being a developer and having
an IDE and working in phase 3
of the SDLC and so on and so forth.
Finding ways to expand the value
of agentic concepts beyond those qualifications
has certainly been one of the driving forces
in where Quiro and Q Developer have gone
over the last 12 months.
Uh, specifically to be more reflective of
the full SDLC and
the complete list of personas who interface
with it. So, our customers
started talking with us, with the primary question being,
where are folks spending their time in the SDLC?
Because it's not, it's not solely
code creation.
During our discussions, our observation became,
if modern development is
about things other than just the act of development,
how can we bring the value of agents to all
areas of the SDLC where people are working? Or
to put it far more poetically as it says on the slide,
how can the value of agentic AI be more
prevalent? Good
application design is a product of multiple personas
across all six phases of the SDLC from
scope and standards to
documentation and modernization
and measurement. And as a quick matter of note,
uh, the text that's in pink is not random
SDLC verbiage. These are areas and actions
where Akiro
uh through either the CLI or IDE modalities
can influence SDLC task and
toil and collaborate effectively with
the folk who, who actually work in those
phases.
So our view on this ended up being that we needed
to democratize the task
and toil value of agentic AI so that it was
more accessible outside
of the IDE by people who aren't developers
and didn't work in
phase 3 of the SDLC.
So earlier this year, we released
two features to drive that concept.
The command line interface,
meaning no need for an IDE
and a genetic chat, which opens
the door to
conversational natural language engagements
um without having,
uh, I suppose, to manage the context between individual
bespoke agents.
And it has been fascinating to see the
use cases that have boiled up
and been uncovered as a result of this. But one of
my favorites is something that we're socially
starting to call um organic transformation,
which is
when a modernization target is identified
by operations from stage
6 of the SDLC
and it is analyzed,
uh, planned, designed and implemented agenttically
without the need to traverse through half the SDLC
through um process and through phase.
OK. So now we get to have a little
bit of fun. And now I get to take you
through, uh, I, I suppose show
you um how you would effectively
instantiate or do something like organic
transformation,
uh, with the Kro CLI and what that potentially
looks like.
So, In this situation, I'm an ops
engineer at a fictional company. Um, I've received a ticket
saying that our payment processing system is struggling.
Um, you can see some of the details up there.
Uh, there's things like, uh, it
is
CPU utilization is currently 25%,
it's underutilized, it's taking 4.22
hours to run,
uh, 50,000 transactions.
There is a commercial impact, it should be taking
well under an hour.
Now, I should point out that in this scenario,
I used the Qua CLI to query
a very simple Java application that I created
to reflect the process of organic
transformation
within the time that we have.
And the eagle-eyed amongst you will no doubt
have seen a few of the awful, awful things
that I put into this application.
Things like hardcoded database credentials,
I've put in there like artificial timers.
It reads like a laundry list of terrible things
that you should not do to innocent applications.
Um, and
Whilst this is a simple application, it's
also intended to be a really a worst case
example of something
that many companies may have, which is
a modernization target that has
performance and security issues.
So
As a good ops engineer, um, I know that I
need to get into an analytical mindset really quickly
and identify what's happening with this application. So
I open my command prompt, I type Kiro
CLI which drops me straight into the interface, and
from there, it's a very usable
conversational style of engagement.
And as you can see, my initial prompt
says analyze the payment process
of the Java file in the legacy payment
system.
Now, There
are many reasons why this is not a great prompt. In fact, it's,
it's an awful prompt and chiefly
it's things like vagueness and lack of purpose,
but that is by design at this
point in time because
um
we're wanting to see how we can build this up in
a manner that sort of um begets ongoing
and continues improving hygiene.
But nonetheless, within a few seconds, Kira has given us a
response. Um, you can see we've got some of the details
in there, uh, categorized by security. It's
obviously picked up the fact that there's hard um credentials.
It sees SQL injection vulnerabilities
from a performance perspective. It's telling me I'm
not doing any connection pooling. I'm doing a lot of synchronous
processing. There's leaks.
Um, architecturally, I'm missing transaction
management. There's absolutely no error handling. It's,
it's, it's a bit of a nightmare.
But importantly, it's starting to identify risk
and scope,
um, and actions that should be taken
and the priority in which they should be taken and should be
considered. So yes,
Kiro is telling me that there is
performance issues,
but perhaps more importantly,
there are some major security concerns
and in a rather direct manner it's saying that's a priority
we should be um actually looking at.
And as a good ops engineer, um, now's
the time where I get into the power of an iterative
conversation with the service, um, and
I go deeper into the actual analysis.
Um, I do have a Palm file, which means there's integrations.
So, review the Palm file, um,
identify outdated, uh,
dependencies
with security vulnerabilities,
suggest modern alternatives.
Um, so good. My prompting is evolving,
um, and it's becoming a little bit more specific in
my conversation.
And as a result, I'm getting some specifics
in return.
This is good, we're starting to build our context, we're
starting to build our momentum.
You can see there CVEs are starting to surface,
modern alternatives or frameworks are being suggested,
and that's all good because this is some of the
stuff which is gonna make
uh lighter of the action that I'm gonna
have to take in the, in the not too distant
future. So let's quickly
review what we've just done to our SDLC in that very
short interaction by agenttically
actioning it with um,
well, some of the toil that we've got in our daily
environment. So analysis of new functionality,
creation of new features, uh, security
updates, codebase, architectural amendments, all
usually begins in phase one with BAs, tech
BAs, project managers, architects,
uh, working together. And they would normally ensure
some of the toil-based action, uh,
detailed in our working examples such as
scope and usage analysis and
risk capturing.
But by actioning this gentically, we're
moving those tasks
to an agent and we're working iteratively with
that agent to complete that task. And this frees
up the tech BAs, the architects,
and so on to focus on higher value concepts
like analyzing and facilitating,
you know, technical solutions or identifying
the technical aspects of business solutions.
By shifting the toil to an agent, we are
upping the efficiency of stage one. And we're starting
to gather momentum as we start moving into
phase two. So, happy
with the analysis of um the service, I
now move into the planning and
design phase.
And you can see over there, we're saying,
um what are the three immediate improvements I
can make to the payment processing system,
uh, that should have the biggest impact. Focus
on quick wins.
Now, based on the language um that
I've used in my prompt,
Quiro is starting to see that I'm edging forward. And then I'm starting to
look for details that are more related to planning
and design work.
So you'll start to see specifics in the responses,
such as
um replace this with this.
Uh, Quiro is now using the contextual awareness
that we've started to create
and that we're developing to get tactical on the
specifics,
which is a prime example of a toil-based task
that an agent can handle.
And that goes deeper in there.
Uh, in the output into things like vulnerabilities
and
uh DB transaction management and the memory
and resource links, uh, leaks that we spoke
about earlier.
But this is also where we start to see output around
the expected outcome and the
implementation plan.
And if this was real life, we would again be
iterating with Quiro to get very specific
on details like help me create a risk management
plan, help me create an ROI estimate, help
me create those assets that are important. Help me
design this into, you know, to being a cloud service,
and so on and so forth.
And much like we saw with analysis, by using a genetic
chat, we have moved
uh additional tasks to the agent
and we're working iteratively with that agent to
complete those actions.
Planning and design is one of those areas in the SDLC
where there's deep potential for efficiency
through agentic collaboration.
Primarily because you have BAs and
project managers and
uh developers and architects all working in close
collaboration to establish foundational
information like project foundations and what are we actually
gonna do?
And this can be a very toilsome action,
very time-consuming action.
Uh, specifically around some of the topics that you see there
with things like practice and standards and dependencies
and the actual implementation details,
uh, itself.
And now we get into the really,
I suppose, the important part, the um
the uh the the phase that really
matters, which is the idea of implementation.
And you can see,
my prompting is getting far more verbose at this point in
time and far more honest with
Quiro as well. I have a high priority ticket.
About the payment processing performance in the legacy payment
system. Based on all of the context
we have investigated so far,
create a specific and detailed plan to address
the performance and security issues we have uncovered.
Prioritize the plan according to uh
what will have the largest impact
in our organizational priorities of
secure customer data, um,
outstanding customer performance and frugality.
Um. In order to expedite the approval
of this plan,
uh, I need a change review board. I'm gonna have
to go through details like clearly identify
the value in terms of ROI,
success criteria, uplifted customer experience,
and so on and so forth. Identifying
the actual actions, who's responsible for
doing what.
Now, You can clearly see that the
prompting has evolved, it's purposeful, but it's not
restrictive. And as a result, I have
a much richer response, one that I
can work with
within the bounds of my prompt that draws upon the
foundational context that we have been
developing and gathering as we step through
what would normally be phase 1 and phase 2 and phase
3 of our SDLC.
And in this scenario, Quiro outputs a step
by step, uh, implementation plan
that I or anyone or even Quiro itself,
uh, can ergentically complete.
And that's, that's where we
start looking at things like
creating this into an asset that we can take to our
change review boards or work as an escalation
or create integrations with third-party systems.
Like Jura and so on. And importantly,
that includes
the systematic creation
as opposed to the subjective creation
of projected results and the
risks we're planning to mitigate and the
success criteria that may actually contribute
towards what our definition of done uh detail
is actually about. So
what we find happening at this point in time is something we,
that's really interesting that we didn't really quantify
too much at the beginning.
By giving, by giving folk the ability
to designate their task and toil,
gives them the ability to shift their value elsewhere
as they allocate tasks and manage the associated
return. The classic example here being
a senior developer who gets to think as a tech leader
or an ops engineer who gets to think architecturally,
or a project manager who gets to think programmatically,
um, because they are managing and reviewing
outcomes and actions that are always of a specific
standard. Which has some very deep
and inherent uh quality benefits
attached to it,
quality positives attached to it.
Great. OK, so let's go back 5 minutes to the quote
of the polls and apply that lens to everything
that I've just said.
It's still the human
who provides the contextual and tooling wisdom,
the strategy that prevents agents from
assuming in the dark.
This collaboration with agents, addressing
the toil-based activities and humans,
giving, giving humans the ability to
address the higher order values like orchestration and
so on, is a powerful concept.
So, let's take that concept of
human agent collaboration a level lower
and get into the deep details with real
world specifics and for that,
please join me in re-welcoming Paul Thrasher back to
the stage.
Hm. Thanks,
Paul. So,
at Hash Corp, what problem are you trying
to solve?
So, with our Atabas
uh terraform provider
and the ADBs cloud Control terraform
provider,
um, we're seeing constantly
accelerating growth.
So, um, here you can see
we've, uh, we currently have
around 3000 open
issues,
uh, 518,
uh, open PRs last I checked.
Um, And we have over 3000
competitors
or contributors, but only
one software engineering team at
Hash Corp.
So that team is supporting over
5 billion downloads. I think it was
at 5.3 or 5.4 last
I checked,
which is about, uh,
more recently,
uh, over 5 million a day.
So every day they're dealing with,
um, supporting quite, quite a bit of,
um,
users and a growing amount of resources.
That bring in PRs and and issues.
So
how does this team keep up
with the uh constant changes
and growing issues, PRs, downloads,
support, and
um you can see that
you know without any changes it would
increase past our ability to maintain that.
So, it's been hard to scale, of
course.
So scaling the team,
um,
to,
uh, bring on new members on board them,
you need to have uh terraform
experience, SDK which is uh
how you builderraform provider,
uh, Golang
and ADAS uh experience
all within the same engineer and of course
you can train that, but, you know,
as much as you can come in with, uh, for a
new engineer,
obviously helpful.
Uh, writing PRs, um,
you know, of course it's more time consuming
than reviewing them.
It gets our overall velocity
down, so each engineer has to, you
know, keep up. This is,
uh, most of their job.
New contributors, bringing them on, uh,
on boarding, they got to pick up on
standards, the principles, the, the ways
of working,
you know, how, how we operate within Hash Corp
and within this team,
um, which is constantly changing as
we deal with the growth here.
Um, code quality, so,
you know, we need, uh, sanitized
compliant code, of course it's gotta be
high quality always,
um, uh, ideally improving
over time
and so, you know, going
through that, that process of, you know,
hiring, writing the PRs, on boarding
new folks,
um, you've gotta
keep that rigor
and keeping the, the code quality high.
And security risk, as you can imagine.
With our large
customers and the large
scale of Terraform
and AWS,
all those
require a good amount of scrutiny
to make sure that there's no malicious
code getting in through that process as
we bring in all these different competitors.
You can probably imagine some of the risks there
where if code were injected and
gets into our competitors, all of a sudden, you
know, they've got their own code
within banks and. Um,
other security products all over the place.
And all that,
of course, ends up with this review bottleneck
with the um amount of
external um
contributors also, they all need
experts reviewing that, that have
that, that expertise
um in those different uh technologies
and services.
And so this limits the
amount of viewers we can have,
but also just the time it takes to get through
that. So, I think the point here
is that it's, it's tough to scale this,
and so you've got to
consider what are your options of over
time, how do you make improvements to your
process and keep up with that
load. So,
of course, mainly it's a lot of hard work,
um.
You know, but also now we get,
we get some AI here.
We, we,
uh, I've worked with the raw models, uh,
you know, building things in-house, trying different
approaches,
and.
I think at at this greater efficiency
doesn't reduce engineering roles, it
expands what teams can achieve.
So
uh what do we want? What are we looking for
out of this? We want our human teams
to be more effective.
You know, we need to scale, scale their work,
their efforts,
uh, we want it to be easier for
our engineers and external teams
maintaining their own providers, so it's not just about
this AWS team too.
uh Sasha Corp, we're trying to scale these efforts
across,
um, uh, many partners,
and we already spent a lot of time
here through these maintenance cycles,
um. The different investments in,
you know, working through the PRs and reviews
and, and scaling, you know, our,
our hosting services, um,
along with our ability to
keep up with more contributors.
So it's not new for us.
Uh, so we've explored AI
as an option, of course.
Um. We,
uh, explored,
you know, trying just the raw models, you know, early
days, uh, a year or so
ago before agents,
uh, or even now you can see how
potentially the throughput might be
faster because you can paralyze a bunch of work.
Um, it can be faster to,
to implement,
um, as far as, you know, getting these
things along a path, maybe throwing in a
CICD or some kind of um
consistent process,
uh, when changes come in.
And it's, it can be good
for exploration or trying things out,
but the results have been unpredictable
for us.
They're hard to repeat, you know, just because
you, you know, prompt one thing one way,
it's not going to work,
um, the same for another similar resource. You need pretty in-depth
understanding of these resources.
And um it depends really
heavily on, on
the, the prompting, and
um these are kind of operating those
once, once the results come out.
We've cried, uh, instruction-based
agents, so that's most of the agents you've seen
out there.
Um, they're good for,
you know, guiding us along those workflows.
Um, they can follow patterns,
um, that we set if, if you
follow them along with them,
and, uh, you know, it doesn't need
too much structure
or, or checkpoints.
In some cases, you can try to get it, you know, the
one shot
results and see how far you can get,
uh, if it goes in codes for 30
minutes for you,
uh, but it's still limited by the prompting
as, as Paul was showing us,
um. You still need that
user vigilance to um
check in on the code and make sure it's good. And
it can still,
um, between
implementations, drift along,
uh, misinterpret, uh,
kind of go in the wrong directions.
So,
we've also uh recently tried
spec-driven agents with uh Quiro,
now that Quiro's been out. Um,
We've seen it delivering uh
consistent high quality work for us, which has
been great, of course,
and we get well-defined requirements
after we put that, that uh
kind of rigor and, and pre-prompting in,
and it's been
great for the kind of
complex work that we've done
within the, the AWS provider.
I think the,
the caveat there is that it,
it takes a lot of the
upfront uh thinking and design,
um. But
this is, we already do this at Hash Corp. That's
part of our process anyway, as you know, you
see with the SDLC,
um, we, we're already going through these
phases, so that upfront thinking
just kind of matches,
matches our flow anyway.
So, um, we've got
fun numbers. This was, um,
honestly great for us and really encouraging
with, um, you know, 90%
faster output
for the development time for, um,
some of our
provider resources and, and actions
as, as I'll show you.
So we've also developed
over 700
high quality configuration documentation
resources.
So, you know, I think
there's, you know, thousands of resources
that we're managing and having to keep up
with and develop and so the documentation
of that is a big part
we've, we've applied AI to that as well.
And the qualities uh stayed
high. Um, we get quick
iteration speeds,
and, you know, it, it comes along with
the, the tests and different controls through
that process as well.
Throughout development, um, uh, we've
built over 6 terraform
resources, and, and the time spent there,
um, was significant before.
And so we've gotten over 6,
so far that I think this was a week or
two ago
when I, when I checked this number.
It's, it's definitely higher now, but also
5/5 terraform
actions have been created so far.
And so overall efficiency,
we've seen
around 90% time savings, and that's
been across the actions,
the terraform resources, which
in some cases a terraform
resource might take a full 40 hours of
work to develop, and we've
seen that brought down to about 4 hours.
So, great, great speed up for us, um,
really encouraging.
So how do we follow the
SDLC process at, at Hasha Corp?
Um, within this, uh, analysis
and, and
planning stage,
we produce PRFAQs
and PRDs. I, I believe PFAQs
came from Amazon, uh, nice thing to, to
steal from them.
Um, so that's kind of the, the pre-planning, that's
a lot of,
um, you know, product management work or,
uh, highly collaborative with the engineering still, but
that, that pre-work to figure out what, what we need
to go, go out and build.
Um, RFCs, um,
have been used forever at, at
Hasha Corp,
and that's kind of the process of
the, um,
engineers
pre-designing what they're gonna go build,
kind of calling the shots, um, you know, so
through that design implementation phase,
and then of course engineering
happens all within our IDEs and,
uh, GitHub.
With the testing and integration,
uh, you know, we have, have the usual,
uh, unit and integration tests, of course.
Um, but with the AWS, uh,
Terron provider,
It's, it's fairly large, and as you can
imagine, doing integration tests across
every single AWS service is,
uh, not just slow, but, uh,
expensive. So that's more of an async,
uh, less often process.
But for us, documentation is also
key. So that's, that's a huge part. If
we can't bring that to you in a way that you
can, um, consume and understand it,
then, you know, we didn't do our job. It's, it's
not, it's not useful for anybody.
So through the, the maintenance process, um,
that's back to that uh cons
constant vigilance
and going through those, those
issues and PR reviews that kind
of feedback into that,
that, um, analysis and planning stage.
So, uh, I'll kick off the first
demo here. Um, so
we'll show off how we, uh,
applied the SDLC phases
within Quiro.
And, um, we're gonna be building
a new terraform action for the, the
ADOS provider.
So actions are new to Terraform.
There's not, you know, the, the models don't
understand them.
Um, they understand building it
within. Uh, you know, the Gola, if
you search Google for, for terraform,
anything, it's going to give you a bunch of HCL
code. So on this side,
it's kind of unknown to, to a lot of
the usual processes that, that you'd
hope would just work for you.
And uh so in this case, it's gonna
be a Dynamo DB crate
backup, which just triggers backups
for Dynamo DB.
And this is all real code we're gonna, we're gonna ship
as well.
So, this is the analysis and planning stage.
We started creating the, the steering docs.
Uh, Kira helps with that. I think in some
cases, it's just one click, it'll kick it off
for you. So,
we, you know, we go through those PRVQ and PRD
stages,
and, at Hash Corp, and it kind of
reflects our
typical process, just as it is now
in the Kira way of doing that.
And in some cases you might
wanna do these as separate steps
working with your team
so iterate uh collaboratively,
um, throw those in the repo,
get feedback,
um, but we wanna show an end to end demo here
of, of how we work so we just kind
of go through it quickly and it's sped up
because, um,
you know, the LMs aren't, aren't the quickest
thing to run through when we wanna show the, the
full, the full stage here.
So, uh, the spec here is
how to,
uh, read the repo.
And, uh, kind of work
in the way that we want.
So we had one of the, the bustron
provider uh engineers. He's,
he's an excellent engineer. He's built.
Um, a very large amount of
resources already, so he's very familiar with, with
the code base so he can get in there and
prompt it and tell it exactly kind of
how we want to approach this work. So it
is not implementation yet. This is,
you know, writing the spec of how
you want to operate once you start
um
triggering the next work. This is just the requirements.
So, uh, here we, we
write this back out manually based on
the documentation, you can see them including
other files,
and, you know, just giving it good
examples to,
to pull from.
And we allow it to refine the
document. It can make
some updates,
go check out those files, um,
you know, a bit of prompting, and
there we go.
It's,
I love, I love this part,
the LM does, does a bit of work for you, but,
you know, it's, it's grounded in,
you know, what we want out of this process
and out of this document.
So, then those files will be available,
um. Uh, as
part of a library that, that we're building,
so you can create actions similar to we did for
you, for if you're maintaining a terraform
provider. Um
Which is great as a PM I'm
doing a talk, but I also want to extract
some like product value out of this.
So,
in some of this work, um, I'll share
later how we kind of bring it to you guys.
So this is uh phase two,
it's the design
and implementation SDLC stage.
So we asked it to
create the plan for us.
And right away, it kicks off, uh,
kind of writing, writing some code,
doing it step by step.
And Kira's gonna
write the code, code for you based on
those uh
steps that, that you kind of laid out
in the, the task doc.
So it, you know, it's, it's sped up,
but for,
you know, our, our engineering time, that was real
time and how we developed this feature. I think it was,
um, 1 hour 20 minutes total,
so to condense that down into,
uh, about 6 minutes for y'all it speed it
up, but this is, this was the, the real-time
process for us.
And so, um,
he's following along with, with
the LM making sure
that the code is produced properly.
Um, you can see him updating the tasks and
changing that based on the feedback
from those earlier tasks.
And, um,
You know, this is, of course, like
it's going to land in production, so you got to make
sure it's up to that standards and quality.
Uh, in this case, he didn't run into any
major errors. We've been through this
process, uh, a few times.
We used Kiiro's CLI, uh,
before this a few times. That was some of our earlier
improvements. So,
um, Kiro was relatively
new for us, but already he was able to
kind of hit the ground running in a lot of ways
with, with his experience and
working through the code.
And
uh Kira's gonna make sure that this package
that he's building here is consistent with
the other code and the other services that, that
have been developed.
So it's a bit easier when we had a couple of examples,
you know, writing the first ever action,
of course, was a long process of back
and forth with Terraform and
SDK and um other provider
work, but once we had a few,
you can kind of lean on those, those earlier
examples.
So, continued step by step,
make sure it's progressing uh correctly,
and then, um, you know, each
of those tasks as we're going,
they all refer back to those steering notes also.
So, in phase 3, this is
the testing and integration phase,
um,
So, we already started writing the
test here,
according to that task list spec uh
spec list.
So, In the task file,
there's, you know, you go through each of those steps,
and then near the bottom, that's usually where
the, the tests and documentation,
um,
uh, is written out, so you, you'll get to those,
near the bottom.
But, uh, you know, similar to last one,
it's doing live development here
and this is a chance to make sure through these
tests that the code's correct, it's doing the right
things, um,
it's uh the right output that
we expected
and um.
It's writing the unit test for us,
and so we get to kind of make sure it all works.
And after the unit tests, it goes into
end to end testing.
Um, I think he got tripped up on
uh some credentials, you know, you need your AWS
credentials to be able to run these and and test them
out, but he was able to,
um, you know, quickly create a
Dynamo DB and then kick off
that that action to trigger
the backup. Um,
so
we, we did get a test fail here,
but Kira was able to
read the output there and go back into the implementation
and fix that up, and then retest it again,
and then pass.
Thanks, Kiiro.
So we still need to give it human readable
instructions, but Kira's doing
all the actual work and, and the testing,
the actual code,
and we kind of just care about the natural
language um flow and
um
path to assist it.
And
near the end, you'll see it. Um, we
also have it create the docs for us. So
the docs can also take a long time. Uh,
they're based on the API generally,
you know, within,
um, the AWSU reference
docs,
and this is going to follow the, the
standard format here and standards
that are the same in our other docs.
So it's, it's a little bit more tedious,
but, you know, it's still kind of formulaic
as far as the docs because we often need uh
support so many of them.
So, you can kind of see how we're
coding
with the agent rather than just Quiro
doing everything by itself.
And, um, you know, from there, of
course, we move it into a PR with GitHub,
and then
see what AI friend we can get to
review the code to.
So, um,
we're thinking, as we're developing this,
you know, how can we help you all,
uh, with your AI workflows,
you know, what, what does Hashi Corp
have, have for the rest of us?
Um.
You know, that was uh central
kind of part of the workflow
that, that we've been developing and working
through is through, um,
MCP uh uh servers,
and we kind of wanted to bring some of that efficiency
to our users.
So, um, you've probably seen a bunch
of talks around MCP or
included them, uh, this week, but,
um, you know, what's our perspective, you
know, how do we think about it?
Uh, it's for us, open source
project, um, it, it gives
you, helps assist with your
kind of AI workflows.
It's, uh, brings context
into
that developing environment, um, as
you're working through. We, we're actually seeing some.
Uh, more IT business use cases
coming out, out of our MCP servers
as well, even just,
uh, for term forms specifically,
but it, you know, it kind of gives us that connection
between our tools and the models,
uh, you know, within, within the agent or even
other contexts,
and then we get the quick plug and
play integrations
and, um.
Uh,
you know, we've seen,
we, we can write this MCP server,
go give it to partners, place it in other
products, which is something we've
not really been able to do before.
So, um, our MCP,
uh, server within Quiro, um,
you know, you kind of see some of the, the, the
quick setup here, but, um,
example prompt might be something like,
I need help setting up my S3 storage buckets
within Terraform.
It's a very common task,
but it's one you usually still have to
go down over to the docks, go look
that up, and so in this
case, the uh MCP
server will uh work
within that workflow and
uh kind of same pattern that you
might do. I kind of see it as,
you know, we have these workflows within our products
either open source uh or
um commercially
and uh we just want to assist
with those.
And so this one will search uh
content within the registry,
and it can
uh pull content from multiple
docs to kind of triangulate how
to create a resource and
you know, combine those results and create,
create the,
the resources you need.
So, um,
quick demo, I just want to show off
our MCP server within Quiro.
So, could you help me create an S3 bucket using
Terraform? So it's simple use
case, uh,
when you might have done a bunch, I've
created so many buckets. I don't
know at this point, uh, I've lost track.
But, um,
it's, it's gonna just
start from scratch. That was empty repo there.
And it uses our MCP server, and
it got the latest provider version.
Uh, it works with all the providers, not just AWS.
But also checks multiple
vir resource docs, it's gonna grab the
best one for, for that context.
Um, and it's nice that the model just knows
how, how to do that, and the, and the agent supports
that. And then
you could, you know, take all this information,
feed it back into those steering docks,
um, for Quiro, but, you know, we're keeping
it simple within this demo at least.
And uh we can also
ask it to use public or private modules
for you. Um, so if you're in HTB
terraform,
you probably have your own best practices
built into,
to policy and modules, and
you can grab that. And um
here we have it follow a CIS
policy that it grabs from that registry,
and it even updates the code
to uh conform.
To the policy here
And so,
uh,
later, you'll see it. It also works
along with the terraform CLI.
So, you know, our, yeah, here it is.
Uh, so it'll do some formatting. It doesn't really
make sense to have MCP
run a format for you when it knows
the CLI very, very well.
So it just runs that.
And,
um, you know,
for basic uh formatting and
validation, I think that's, that's a great
use case for those.
Otherwise, I,
I personally don't think that
agents should be running
the rest of terraform, plan and apply that,
um.
You know, we, we have, uh,
HP terraform to help you go through that
process for collaboration and, um,
security. So in
the end we get a
S3 bucket, uh, with logging
and policies, and it, it's
made sure it's not public.
So it follows, you know, not
just best practices, but
the policies that are within your business
and it's usable in production
conforms to
what you would expect from, you know, any
human. Um, going through the
PR process.
So, uh, what's next for Hasha Corp?
Um, we're,
we've been introducing a bunch of AI
first, uh, development practices.
So,
um, we've kind of
doubled down on that human-agent
partnership,
and we've, um, kicked
off a dedicated team just
for, uh, provider
development and authoring, uh, configuration
with AI agents. So I think you'll see a lot
more, uh, assistance there, more tooling,
um.
And
we also learned
about uh Kiiro Powers along with
everyone else this week,
uh, a few days ago, and yesterday
we quickly produced, uh, pulled
together our docs and MCP server.
Um, we got legal approval and
and marketing
support, and we
went out as a launch partner yesterday,
um, even though we just learned about it this week.
We developed, you know, these specs and different,
different aspects of it.
Um, and we're gonna launch elsewhere,
but we now have, uh,
Hashcore, terraform, uh,
cure Power.
So, uh, that team is gonna be working
on things like that, that help you, uh,
develop your config and also,
uh, Terraphone providers.
So,
uh,
you know, we'll, we'll be giving out official
agent documentation for Cairo and
other agents, providing some of these,
you know, each of these tools kind of have their
own proprietary,
um, support, so we'll be, uh,
building for that.
And then, um,
you know, I think this helps, uh, Hash
Corp, IBM, our partners, the,
the whole ecosystem, our users, um,
it makes it a lot easier to, to work
within these kind of AI agent
contexts.
And uh there's a lot more to come
from us, I think,
um, hoping to accelerate quite a bit
with uh AI within Hash Corp
and pull in newest ideas
from the rest of the industry, which is of
course um how we've always operated
and
so very, very similar processes now
that AI is in play.
So,
you can go check out our Terraform
MCP server, um,
Uh, take a look at that. We've got some QR
codes leave up for, for a minute.
And we've also
built them for Vault and Vault radar.
I think you'll see more to come.
But through there, also check out
our Qro
Power, and I think soon
you'll see documentation around
best, uh, best ways to use
this MCP server
and these various, um,
AI agents along with, with Terraform.
So. Thank
you, Paul.
Thank you, Paul, much appreciated. And before we wrap
up in a minute or two's time, I did just want
to very quickly, uh, publicly doff
my hat and acknowledge
the work that you and the team have done as part of,
you know, the incredible gains you've gotten around things
like 90%
time back into the day of your people. So well done to you and the
team for everything that you've done in that process.
Really is an amazing result.
So, between Paul and I, we've talked about the, the
many ways that uh, you know, the agents are transforming
the SDLC. We've gone through things like
uh backlog grooming, we've talked about things like,
you know, requirements generation, we've talked about
intelligent orchestration and so on.
This holistic integration of agents
into the SDLC is
kind of changing it from being a bit of a linear sequential
process to being something that's a bit more dynamic
and loop.
Shaped in the way that it goes.
Where it goes is something that's gonna be really interesting for
all of us to watch over the next, over the next
very short period of time.
But one thing it is doing is enabling the efficiency
and the quality of delivery that Paul has just
been covering. And
to, uh, I know we keep harping on this point, but
none of that actually occurs without that synergistic
relationship where humans and agents
co-create.
Um, and that goes across things like ops engineers
using agents for things like infrastructure orchestration
and monitoring and
incident response and so on. But it also goes
to tech BAs who are using
it to analyze requirements and create user
stories. And if you're a purist like me
and you love the win then shall approach to user
stories, have a look at what Quiro can do.
Um, it also goes into things like architects
and, uh, simulating system designs
and doing things like, uh,
ensuring compliance, assessing scalability,
uh, project managers for sprint planning and
stakeholder communication and risk analysis.
The result is a more inclusive and
efficient development
environment where every role contributes meaningfully
to software delivery, and that's an exciting concept.
Um
If I was to crystal ball the next 12 months, I
think this is what it would look like for me.
Um, without doubt, agents are gonna gain
greater, um, autonomy, um,
such as, you know, when they, when we start to uncover
use cases like organic transformation that we
spoke about and the, and the adoption thereof.
But that's directly linked to something that's that
we're calling true collaboration,
which doesn't mean heavier collaboration in,
in this context. It means effective oversight,
which, as we discussed, is one of the keys
to that human agent partnership.
And lastly and finally, our 3rd and final point
for the session for the day is higher quality
output. Um, from the SDLC
means a quicker, straighter path
to organizations and developers
capturing the opportunities that they're working on
through software, um, through software creation.
So where can you learn more?
There is still one of these things happening at this point in
time. If you haven't gone and seen the
house of Kiiro yet, which is in this building in the
Venetian,
level 2 in front of the expo,
go through and have a look and a walk through the spooky
house of Quiro. It's an exciting little thing to do. It's
kind of a cool experience. And there's great swag on
the other side as well.
So thank you everybody for your time today. We really
appreciate you spending an hour with us. It's been fantastic.
Thank you Paul for being on stage with me.
Travel safe back home and we look forward to seeing you next year.
Thank you.